thank you thank you thank you
I have to where is max okay I don't need
you okay listen I think this is very
unfair you get to see me face front
if I want to see myself I only get my
back we got to reverse this thing
somehow you having all the fun
okay I don't know why I'm here I assume
you'll he won't tell me cuz he's busy
got more important stuff to do all right
now then what am I doing here and what
do I have to do not to get in trouble no
please all right here we go okay you're
almost your real story is almost like
the story of the comic book industry
itself
you go back to 1939 the superheroes came
along then
but you've over the years you've made
them into something else what we are
what we have today is a hold to you so
when it's when you win uncle Robbie took
the downloading the glooms office what
are your thoughts about comics and now I
have a confession to make
even though I obviously look like the
most perfect physical specimen you have
ever seen my hearing isn't as good as it
used to be and when my friend talks into
this mic so put the bike away
when I was a kid what was my Oh last
week
what would well I thought the same about
comics last week is I've always sort of
Adam I think that comics are one of the
greatest types of breathing matter in
the world because you have pictures you
have words Steven Spielberg once said to
me see now you can tell him a
name-dropper
but he once said to me you know Stan you
and I do essentially the same thing
except my pictures move of course that
was before we went into movies and now
our pictures move do we'll get to that
later anyway what was the question in
the early days when I first came into
the leader the industry and coming for
just coming together see how its
translator
what were my thoughts all right I'm
going to answer honestly because you'd
expect nothing less from me my thought
was I hope these books will sell so that
I'll keep my job and be able to pay the
rent that was about as exotic as my
thoughts ever gotten
we didn't know in those days we didn't
know that one day they'd be coming book
conventions with fans like you with with
all the excitement and the publicity and
the fun and they get together and the
collecting in fact talking about
collecting I hate to say this but we
lived it we worked in a little office
back then the name of the company was
timely Cummings before Atlas before
after that it became marvel so back in
the forties I guess or 50s on that good
of years we were timely comics and the
artwork
went to the printer and when the book
was printed the printer sent the
original artwork back to us and we
didn't have room to keep it in our
offices they were small offices so if a
guy would come up to the office
delivering a sandwich from the store
downstairs we'd say hey fella on your
way out would you take this artwork with
you
and we did the same with the scripts we
had no idea that one day these things
would be worth something we just wanted
to get rid of them so we have room in
the office
to move around and if that doesn't bring
it tear to your eye you have no
sentiment like I'm married to see County
with great difficulty
no it you mentioned that I was
disenchanted can you hear me okay well
that's your tough luck I I have been
writing the kind of comic books that my
publisher wanted me to write in the very
beginning and that was before the
Fantastic Four and he had absolutely no
respect for his readers he figured they
don't particularly want to read anything
they just want to look at pictures of
people fighting and shooting each other
and beating each other up so he used to
say don't worry about a story don't
worry about characterization don't worry
about good dialogue just give me a lot
of accent that's what they want well I
wanted to be paid so I did what he
wanted for years and one day I said I
can't do this anymore
so I said to my wife I think I want to
quit and look for another job she said
to me in words of wisdom because we all
know how wise wives are she said Stan
why don't you do a book the way you'd
like to do it
the worst that happens is he'll fire you
but you want to quit anyway
so I thinking that was good advice and I
did the Fantastic Four I figured I'm
gonna get characters that maybe have
some personality and I'll play up the
characterization and so forth and I'll
try to get real stories besides just
action well the Fantastic Four sold like
crazy so my publisher was no dummy came
running into me and he said to some
books like the Fantastic Four so that
was now what was becoming fun I don't
remember the order we did them in but
then I did the x-men and spider-man and
oh and all the others and they all did
well so now I enjoyed my work and
everything was different was that a good
answer okay I want to please anybody
very power if you've heard this before
you are free to read a comic book while
I talk the others might wanna listen
how how spider-man was created after the
Fantastic Four was selling well and I
think the x-men were selling well Martin
that was my publisher came in to me and
said Stan come on up with something else
well I wanted to do something different
and I thought what can I do now when you
do a superhero character the most
important thing is to figure out what
superpower will you give them and I
thought I had used up all the
superpowers
I think I had already done the Hulk who
was the strongest guy in the world
we had the Human Torch who could burst
into flame and fly at the Invisible Girl
and on and on and then I saw a fly
crawling on the wall and I said wow
wouldn't that be cool if we could get a
superhero who could crawl on walls like
a no I'm lying I probably didn't say
wouldn't that be cool because the word
cool wasn't in use yet I probably said
wouldn't that be groovy
because I don't want to lie to you
anyway I thought that was good so now
the next thing you need is a name so I
figured how about insect man but it
didn't sound heroic
why man didn't have it I went down the
list mosquito man and then I got to love
that name so then in order to make them
really different I thought I'm gonna
make him a teenager because there were
no teenage superheroes I knew and then I
said I'm gonna give him a lot of
personal problems because I didn't know
any superhero who had personal problems
the only personal problem Superman had
was when he takes off his glasses people
might know who he is so I went right
singing it rushing in Thank You Superman
lovers
I went rushing into Martin's office and
I said I got a new superhero for you
and I told him what my idea was and he
said in words that will live in infamy
forever
he said Stan that is the worst idea I
have ever heard he said first of all you
can't call somebody spider-man because
people hate spiders then you say you
want him to be a teenager a teenager can
only be a sidekick what's the matter
with you and then he said you mean you
want him to have personal problems
superheroes don't have personal problems
as sophinarose he did everything but
take me out of the office well I was
heartbroken but we had a magazine that
we were planning to kill I think it was
called amazing fantasy now when you're
gonna kill a magazine nobody cares what
you put in the last issue are you
telling it anyway so just to get it out
of my system I put spider-man in the
last issue
amazing fantasy and I featured him on
the cover and I forgot about it a month
later the sales figures came in and
Martin came running into my office and
I'll never forget what he said he said
Stan do you remember the character
spider-man of yours that we both loved
so much
I swear he said let's make him a series
and that's how Spidey was born
you didn't believe in teenage sidekicks
I hate it teenage sighs look if I were a
superhero or even a person would I go
around with a teenage sidekick at the
very least people would talk
I kind of remember that an interesting
if you now look about the Marvel
Universe with that knowledge you will
see they don't exist in the Marvel
Universe since they didn't like them
everybody else's follows where did all
the creative ideas come from and the
energy mostly hunger we had to make a
living and I was always propelled by
that one that one thing that propels us
all greed no I enjoyed what I was doing
obviously if you do something and it's
well received by the public you get a
kick out of it so here we had the
Fantastic Four the x-men spider-man and
the books were selling like crazy scope
Martin kept saying come up with new ones
but he didn't even have to say it was
such fun doing this I would have done it
anyway so I think it would I not get a
blind superhero nobody would believe
that and I did daredevil and that turned
out pretty good and then we do end up
the strange by the way they're working
on Doctor Strange as a movie you'll be
seeing him through and you may have
heard
during a movie of ant-man they're going
to use a very little camera that they do
in movies of everything guardians of the
galaxy
I did it I'll tell you a secret about my
cameo in guardians of the galaxy I I
can't tell you what it is because I'm
not allowed to tell what my cameos are
because obviously that's the only reason
people go to the movies to see but I
will tell you this I have absolutely no
idea what the Cameo I did has to do with
the story it has nothing to do with
guardians of the galaxy well you'll see
what I mean when you see them oh when I
came here to London was it yesterday the
day before yesterday when we landed I
ran over to the studio where they were
shooting the Avengers and I did my cameo
I did my cameo for the Avengers and it
is very funny I know you have no
interest in seeing the Avengers but go
see it for my cameo you'll get a picture
let's think about the cameos I'm gonna
let you in on a little secret this is
for those of you who are interested in
business the business people here who
say to yourself how can Marvel get as
much money as possible at the box office
so here's what they decided you may
wonder why I was not in the last x-men
movie which has that shown here already
the later you I know you were all
heartbroken because I wasn't in it he is
the reason I wasn't in it and it's very
shrewd on the part of Marvel they know
if anybody goes to the movie and doesn't
see my cameo they'll figure oh I must
have blinked my eye or maybe I was
reaching down for the popcorn and I
missed it so what do they do they run to
the box office and buy another ticket
because nobody wants to miss my cameo so
every so often they leave one out so
that the movie will make twice as much
as it would have made that's a little
secret I don't want you to tell anybody
about it I am going to show you why I am
such a great guest he asked me how I
felt when I saw what a big hit our first
movie was right and this is why people
come to Emmy speak because my answers
are so philosophical and meaningful it
felt good
now they're healthier think about the
funny thing is I can't take credit for
the movies I may have created the
characters but the movies are done by
the best directors and screenwriters and
actors
marbles feathers no expense to getting
the best and that's why the movies are
so good and TC is trying also you know
that in their own humbling way oh I'll
tell you something else
little secret do you know how DC could
make a hit out of their next movie all
they have to do is give me a cameo in it
nobody would believe that they'll say
I've gotta see that movie I don't
believe it I can't wait to see it and
you're free to tell the people at DC
anytime you wish next 72 you gave up
writing comics you move more into the
admin side of it then you move down to
Hollywood but how did I feel
moving away from the comics into Los
Angeles land of glamour with beautiful
women with movies with television with
music I felt pretty good no look at it
this way saying take you get standard
shut up look at it this way I had spent
I don't know how many years writing
those comics after a while you figure I
mean okay there's nothing left to prove
I'm not going to spend my life writing
comics so it was oh I tell you how I
happened to go to the coast somebody
else was doing some animated cartoons of
our characters out in Los Angeles and
for some reason when I became the
publisher I had to go out to Los Angeles
to talk to those people
I think my but I had never been to Los
Angeles before and the weather was
beautiful the Sun was shining there was
greenery all over and people driving
open convertibles it looked like Evan so
when I got back to New York I said I've
got to find a way to move to Los Angeles
that I got it
dear I called the meeting of the
executives at marble and I said you know
Marvel shouldn't have other companies
producing their animated cartoons marble
should produce its own animated cartoons
we should form a production company and
then tamed the clinker I said I am
willing to make the supreme sacrifice I
will move my family out to the coast and
set up a production unit do it for
Marvel well there wasn't a dry eye in
the place you would do that for a stand
and I said yes because I love you so I
moved out to the coast to set up a
studio and I never had more fun Thank
You fun lovers to areas of euphoria so
much the pile entertainment
did you know still tonyia new concepts
new heroes what is it what what is it to
want to keep offering the public more
clearly well it wasn't so much that I
wanted it give the public more and more
heroes I love entertainment and I love
the idea of entertaining the public and
I would entertain the public any way I
could I've done things beyond heroes we
had I don't you know we have a little
character in the Fantastic Four called
Willie Lumpkin he was a mailman or
something I did a newspaper strip called
Willie Lumpkin of the years you know it
put in features and I did a lot of
magazines you were magazines one of them
I loved it was
well you don't say I would take photos
of celebrities and I put funny captions
things that they couldn't possibly be
saying over their head in fact because
I'm a name-dropper I'll tell you this I
was at a dinner once with President
Ronald Reagan and somebody snapped a
photo of us and he was sitting there he
was the table and I was sitting here we
were facing each other now I said to
myself when I sat down what do you say
to the ex-president of the United States
what am I gonna say to him so the only
thing I could think of I said gosh mr.
president you must be so relieved that
you're out of office now and you don't
have the responsibility of the world on
your shoulders and he said no I love
being president that photo before I sat
down I'm standing above them he's at the
table and he's looking up at me so I
wrote a caption that said from him a
dialogue balloon from him saying Stan
would you do me a favor and then a
dialogue balloon for me saying sir mr.
Reagan what and then another dialogue
balloon from him would you pose for a
picture with me and it looks so great
actually said that say on top of
everything else I'm a little bit of a
phony okay next what if I don't know the
answers this is Gary this is the part
that terrifies me for when you wrote the
Great American Novel
yes no I don't think I will ever write
the Great American no you know it is I'm
spoiled I don't have the patience when I
wrote those comics I would write the
idea for the story and I would give it
to the artists and I'd say it's the what
it's 21 pages go ahead and draw it and
I'd let the artist or it any way he
wanted then the artist would give me the
pages all drawn in pencil and I'd write
the dialogue I would let her in the
dialogue balloons I'd let her in the
captions I'd let her in sound effects if
they were needed but the point is it
took me one day when Steve Ditko brought
me the spider-man pages in one day I had
it all written because all I was doing
was writing dialogue balloons and sound
effects and captions so I got spoiled
I'm used to writing the whole thing in a
day and the idea of a novel way to sit
we have the we have the week I just
don't have the patience I'd rather be
talking to people
Stanley you are absolute government just
gonna say offensive 12 hours doing
alleged Plus baton so yeah well can I
ask how does it feel to be an
inspiration all over the world from kids
who are from like two to three years old
two fully grown adults like myself it
feels good
it's really hard to believe and it's a
wonderful feeling thank you
hi Stan
I was just wondering since other other
authors and writers and the movie makers
have taken over the characters and
you've obviously seen a lot of different
interpretations of your characters I've
never been Bauman's where you've seen
someone else do something with the
character and you've wished I wish I
total doing that when I was lightens yes
I wish I had thought of Wolverine that
came after I would stop writing the
books and there's another character that
I understand is very popular I have not
read them because I don't have a chance
to read them anymore but there's a
character called Deadpool and if he's
that popular I wish I had thought about
him but don't worry that by next
interview I'll say I did who know how
soon you're gonna go home to see your
wife I don't know I can't think I think
I've been asked every question anybody
could ever imagine I have been to so
many conventions and I'd loved them all
and people shower you with questions but
I think I've heard them all - if you
could cosplay and dress up as any
character who would it be and why well
it wouldn't be the Black Widow
I don't know I kind of like Tony Stark I
think I'd like to dress like a
billionaire thank you very much for New
York lunch Esther
well good for you you know my wife is
English she's from the north of England
and boy I love England and I love the
English I think of myself as half
American and ethic and that Shakespeare
Inu had a right style it's a pleasure to
hear her nice to meet you and I was
wondering if you could write an ending
for any of your characters spider-man
x-men what would these endings be
because the comics going forever and we
never get to see it kind of definitive
end to the characters well I'll give you
one of the most unsatisfactory answers
you've ever gotten I kill him
of course if I were a nice guy I would
retire them I'd have them say well I
think superhero in long enough I think
I'll buy a house near a golf course and
spend my life playing golf or I kill him
it depends what would amended starting
feet married for 66 67 years if your
wife had a superpower what would you say
it is it tolerating me
no I'll tell you a little story about my
wife she's wonderful when I met her she
was an actress she was a model she was a
singer and a dancer
and she had a great career ahead of her
but I tried to be very much so and I
said to her no wife of mine is gonna
work and she said okay and it was the
dumbest thing I ever said she could have
been supporting me all these years I've
been trying to get an extra two or three
questions I've got time for one more and
it's gonna go that what looks like some
of these probably the youngest member of
our audience that's an easy one to
answer even though you again you think
of me as a model of perfection I have a
terrible memory it made it easy for me
to remember the names of my characters
because if they all had a name with the
first name and the last name begin with
the person with the same letter if I
could think of Peter I knew his lest
they began with me so it made it easier
for me to think of the Parker and Bruce
Banner and read oh well the last name
must begin with R how about Richards
just as I have a lousy memory and I hate
telling you this because I'd like you to
think I was perfect
but I'm afraid after this interview
yogurt and know better
Thank You imperfection bubbles
you